>> Tucker: WANT TO SAVE THE
PLANET?
DON’T HAVE KIDS.
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE ARE
COMING TO THAT CONCLUSION.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" JUST
PROFILED THE GROWING GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY ARE
REFUSING TO HAVE CHILDREN
BECAUSE THEY DON’T WANT TO
CONTRIBUTE TO GLOBAL
WARMING.
JOSEPH A PROFESSOR OF
HISTORY AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
HE SAYS THAT’S ABOUT THE
RIGHT IDEA.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
PROFESSOR, THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
>> HEY, THANKS FOR HAVING
ME, TUCKER.
I NEED TO MAKE SOMETHING
CLEAR THOUGH BEFORE WE
START.
I’M FROM SACRAMENTO.
I HAVE TO GIVE A SHOUTOUT TO
ANTHONY SADLER, OUR STUDENT
HERE AT ZAC STATE WHO IS
PLAYING HIMSELF IN THE NEW
CLINTON EASTWOOD MOVIE.
HE GRADUATED 2017.
>> Tucker: I JUST
INTERVIEWED HIM ON FRIDAY.
WHAT A GREAT GUY HE IS.
I’M IMPRESSED.
>> SEE THAT’S EVIDENCE WE
ARE NOT INDOCTRINATING THE
STUDENTS AND TELL THEM TO
WORRY ABOUT TRIGGER
WARNINGS.
>> Tucker: THAT KID IS
BRAVE.
I WILL SAY THAT.
>> GO HORNETS.
>> Tucker: SEE, THAT WASN’T
BAD.
I USUALLY HATE THAT STUFF
BUT THAT WAS A GOOD ONE.
>> THE OTHER THING, I KNOW
THE OTHER THING.
>> Tucker: I CAN’T LET YOU
PROMOTE ANYMORE.
I WILL GET FIRED.
I CAN’T DO THAT I’M SORRY.
>> I’M A SCIENTIST.
HISTORIAN I WROTE THIS BOOK
ABOUT ROBERT KENNEDY.
BETTER BOOK THAN CHRIS
MATTHEWS.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU A
QUESTION.
>> BETTER BOOK THAN CHRIS
MATTHEW’S BOOK.
>> Tucker: THAT’S NOT HIGH
PRAISE.
SO HERE’S THE QUESTION.
YOU THINK PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
FEWER KIDS BECAUSE OF GLOBAL
WARMING.
HIGH THE HIGHEST BIRTH RATES
ARE IN AFRICA.
TOP 15.
SOMALIA, YOU ARE TELLING
AFRICAN WOMEN TO HAVE FEWER
KIDS?
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
>> LET ME, YEAH, THIS IS
GOING TO PUT A IF YOU ARE
ROW IN YOUR BROW, TUCKER I’M
TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE ALTHOUGH I THINK
THAT ARTICLE IS LEGITIMATE
IN THAT IT RAISES SOME
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS, IT’S
REALLY A DUMB ARTICLE THAT
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT.
BECAUSE WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
DO STOP REPRODUCING THE
SPECIES?
IT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
CHILDREN.
I DON’T BELIEVE WE SHOULD
STOP HAVING CHILDREN.
I BELIEVE WE SHOULD LOOK TO
THE FUTURE AND LOOK WHAT THE
MARKETS ARE TELLING US RIGHT
NOW IS THAT RENEWABLES,
CAPACITY IS INCREASING.
GLOBAL CAPACITY FOR
RENEWABLES IN ELECTRICITY
GLOBALLY BY 2020, 2025 IS
GOING TO BE INCREASED BY
40%.
THERE IS GOING TO BE.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, THAT’S
PARTLY TRUE.
I MEAN WIND IS A JOKE BUT
SOLAR IS REAL.
HOLD ON.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
OUT THERE, HOLD ON, THERE IS
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE
ARGUING THAT YOU SHOULDN’T
HAVE CHILDREN OR YOU WANT TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
YOU DO HAVE BECAUSE OF THE
EARTH.
AND THE PRESSURE THAT THEY
PUT ON THE EARTH.
AND MY QUESTION IS ARE YOU
GOING TO TAKE THIS MESSAGE
TO THE COUNTRIES THAT ARE
HAVING THE MOST CHILDREN AND
TWO IT’S A LITTLE APPEAR AT
THIS HUMAN, ISN’T IT THAT
MESSAGE?
>> I’M HISTORIAN.
LET’S GO BACK.
THIS COUNTRY HAS ALREADY
BEEN THROUGH THIS WHOLE
THING, IT’S CALLED EUGENICS
WE DON’T WANT TO GO THERE
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS WORK
ALL TOGETHER, PEOPLE IN ALL
THE WORLD TO FACE A GLOBAL
PROBLEM.
I MEAN FOX BUSINESS NEWS
JUST ON DECEMBER 20TH WAS
URGING ITS READERS TO THINK
ABOUT INVESTING IN
ALTERNATIVE FUEL STOCKS.
I MEAN, ELON MUSK IS GOING
TO HAVE 100,000 ELECTRIC
SEMI-TRUCKS IN THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS.
HE WANTS TO PRODUCE 100,000
A YEAR.
HE JUST SHOT A TESLA INTO
OUTER SPACE.
THAT’S THE FUTURE.
AND THE STOCKS ARE SHOWING
THAT.